europe a pour la première fois depuis le
traité de rome réussi à emprunter de
l'argent en commun un grand pas pour la
construction européenne même si votre
parti était opposé
exactement c'est comme ça je pense quand
même maintenant on paie plus haut qu'on
reçoit
ça c'est un fait non c'est comme ça et
on verra si on retrouve maintenant la
construction de l'union des des temps ça
se sait quelque chose à craindre ni
parce que ça c'est quelque chose contre
nos principes
ici dans l'union européenne pourquoi
parce qu'en fait on a dit anton est
traitée qu'on veut pas avoir des dettes
communaux et maintenant on a quelque
chose comme ça vous l'avez dit vous-même
et ça c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
la poser des problèmes dans l'avenir
alors vous l'avez sous vide ailleurs à
la cour constitutionnelle allemande elle
était plutôt pas d'accord avec vous
charles goerens au contraire vous dites
c'est une opportunité d'avoir pour la
première fois consenti à une dette
commune à vingt-sept très novatrice
c'est un grand progrès disons que toutes
les crises que nous avons connues jusque
maintenant on est et fédératrice pour
l'union européenne
chaque fois qu'il ya eu une bonne crise
il ya eu un assainissement des
principaux acteurs notamment de la
france et d'allemagne et je crois que
madame merkel a été très lucide on en a
disons bien les intérêts de l'allemagne
et c'est que sans
légion prospères du nord de l'italie
l'allemagne supporterait pas aussi bien
l'allemagne a besoin du marché intérieur
elle a besoin du redémarrage des
économies du sud et de toutes les autres
économies et je trouve que elle se met à
la pointe et pays il dit payeur net
d'euros budget de l'union européenne qui
a bien compris que les intérêts vont
bien au-delà du simple calcul versements
dans le budget européen et c'est qu'on
peut en retirer le nom de solidarité il
est essentiel pour faire redémarrer la
machine alors que les autres ne s'enlise
pas dans la crise au contraire la chine
est reparti avec 18 % de croissance au
premier trimestre de cette année les
assises escompte une croissance
économique de 6 4 % pour l'europe c'est
caca % donc il ya aucune raison pour ne
pas agir et je crois que l'union
européenne a bien fait de décider ce
plan de relance alors justement vous
l'avez dit le plan va en priorité aux
pays les plus touchés par le cos ville
il n'a rien à voir avec les critères de
pibou de bonne gestion
la commission elle examine les plans
nationaux un parent prenant en compte
les critères imposés les investissements
verts et dans le numérique
est-ce que ce contrôle de la commission
et ses critères d'investissement vous
conviennent non pas du tout bien sûr je
sais bien qu'on a une tradition
différentes entre la france et
l'allemagne qu'on ne parle de dirigisme
et de l'interventionnisme de l'état par
exemple mais pour moi bien sûr on a déjà
parlé de ça c'est trop un
je pense que c'est trop de dirigisme par
exemple avec les green deal en de mettre
tous ces choses ensemble tous ces
nécessités ensemble et d'intégrer cette
green deal par exemple dont les tons les
mesures pour moi c'est trop de dirigisme
et ses trous d'état dans la liberté de
la économies mais vous voudriez pas le
au contraire beaucoup de dirigisme de la
commission européenne pour juger les
réformes structurelles
que ce que ce plan est liée à des
réformes structurelles ou est liée à des
engagements d'une certaine orthodoxie
budgétaire
non ça c'est une autre chose au monde
l'autre du xi autour d'auxi budgétaire
c'est quelque chose qu'on en dise qu'on
a besoin parce qu'on doit on doit
contrôler lire ou va largement par
exemple mais à les nécessités de green
day par exemple de ça c'est trop à mon
avis non alors vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ça monsieur je suis pas du tout
d'accord
d'ailleurs mon collègue vient d'un pays
où il y à une redistribution budgétaire
à l'intérieur de la fédération
l'allemagne est une république fédérale
et ses composantes sont et l'inde des
pays comme le banc john baird qui est
très voisin de la france la bavière les
autres pays riches en allemagne paye des
contributions au budget central qui
redistribue l'argent à des régions qui
ont des problèmes structurels et plus
qui plus est depuis 1989 l'allemagne a
fait des efforts financiers énormes pour
relever les pays de l'est pour faire
redémarrer les pays de l'est ce nom je
crois que ce point de vue c'est que fait
l'europe c'est à peu près ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne c'est très comparable cet
effort de solidarité
deuxièmement je crois que l'union
européenne a tout intérêt à se
comprendre comme entité d'ailleurs dans
les traités dette inscrit que l'union
européenne que tous les pays sont dans
un processus
l'union européenne sans cesse plus
étroite donc moi je suis fidèle au
traité d'abord parce que c'est un ça
concerne notre sécurité
ça c'est rassurant pour les citoyens qui
sont en quête de stabilité
[Musique]